bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voulais
vous faire une petite vidéo de réactions
à chaud à cet événement qui est en train
de secouer le monde de l'intelligence
artificielle et le monde du jeu de go je
veux parler du fait que un algorithme un
programme informatique qui s'appelle
alpha go qui a été développée par une
filiale de google vient de battre lycée
dole qui est un des meilleurs joueurs de
go du monde à l'heure actuelle si ce
n'est le meilleur
alors ça peut paraître un peu étonnant
que tout le monde s'excite sur cette
nouvelle là quand on sait que ça fait à
peu près vingt ans que un ordinateur a
battu le champion du monde d'échecs à
dire quelque part on pourrait penser que
ce n'est pas très surprenant qui se
passe la même chose avec legault mêmes
pourraient être surpris que ça ait pris
20 ans pour qu'on arrive à faire avec
legault ce qu'on savait déjà faire avec
les échecs
donc aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
expliquer pourquoi en fait le jeu de go
et le jeu d'échecs sont vraiment très
différent qu'est ce qui explique qu'on
ait mis si longtemps avant d'être
capable d'avoir une forme d'intelligence
artificielle capable de battre le
meilleur joueur de go du monde où l'un
des meilleurs joueurs de go du monde et
aussi même vous expliquer pourquoi un
certain nombre de personnes pensaient
que ça prendrait encore plus longtemps
attendait plutôt ça pour dans 10 ou 15
ans alors pour comprendre ça en fait il
faut se pencher un peu évidemment sur
les règles du go alors moi je suis pas
joueur de bourama je vais essayer de
vous expliquer basiquement le
fonctionnement des règles donc legault
c'est un jour jeu qui se joue à deux
joueurs il y en a un qui prend les noirs
et l'autre qui prend les blancs et ça se
joue pas sur un damier ou un échiquier
ça se joue sur une grille c'est une
grippe c'est là le goban je crois c'est
une grille de 1,19 par 19 et donc le
principe du jeu c'est que chaque joueur
a des pions alors apple passe à des
pions ou qu on appelle ça des pierres et
chaque fois que c'est son tour de jouer
il prend une de ces pierres et il la
pose sur une des intersections de la
grille sur le sur le plateau la
différence avec un jeu comme les échecs
ou les dames c'est que les pierres une
fois posée elle bouge pas il n'y a pas
de notion de déplacement de mouvements
des pierres sur le plateau pas du tout
en fait c'est très simple chaque joueur
à son tour de jouer prendre de ces
pierres et la pause sur une des
intersections de la crise et donc quand
on démarre en fait le plateau est vide
et au fur et à mesure de la partie
le plateau se remplit et alors c'est
quoi le but du jeu en gros c'est
d'encercler des territoires et notamment
d'essayer d'encercler des pions de
l'adversaire si jamais vous arrivez à
encercler des pions de l'adversaire vous
pouvez les capturer et donc c'est comme
ça qu'on marque des points
voilà en gros pour pour les règles les
règles du jeu de go alors maintenant
essayons de comprendre qu est ce qu il
faudrait qu'on fasse si on voulait
essayer de faire un algorithme qui soit
capable de jouer au gault alors on va
tout simplement se placer dans la
situation du jeu d'échecs
alors imaginez vous êtes vous êtes un
programme informatique vous êtes en
train de jouer aux échecs vous êtes au
milieu d'une partie et c'est à vous de
jouer et donc vous devez décider quel
est le prochain coup à jouer alors il ya
une méthode qui est assez simple qu'on
peut faire si on est si on a un
ordinateur c'est tout simplement
d'essayer tous les coups possibles
donc voilà imaginons vous êtes dans une
certaine position vous regardez tous les
coups possibles
et puis pour aller plus loin on peut pas
seulement regarder tous les coups qu'on
peut jouer mais on peut regarder aussi
toutes les réponses possibles que
l'adversaire peut faire à ses couleurs
et puis on peut pousser plus loin on
peut aussi regarder toutes les réponses
qu'on peut faire à ses réponses et on
peut faire ça sur sur plusieurs niveaux
et comme ça envisager toutes les
situations possibles en anticipant trois
quatre cinq six coups par exemple donc
on anticipe toutes les situations
possibles sur un certain nombre de coups
on regarde quelle est l'issue la plus
favorable pour nous et puis on décide de
jouer
le coût correspondant donc à ces deux
méthodes finalement assez c'est assez
brutal et qu'on appelle recherche en
arbre pour une raison évidente c'est à
dire qu'on construit un peu l'arbre de
toutes les possibilités sur plusieurs
coups et puis on choisit pas le coup qui
nous avantage le plus donc ça aux échecs
ça peut marcher relativement bien ça
demande pas mal de puissance de calcul
mais une technique comme ça peut donner
des d'assez bons résultats
alors en fait au go une méthode comme ça
ça marche pas du tout est en fait il ya
une raison pour ça c'est que quand vous
jouez au go le nombre de possibilités de
coûts est bien plus important qu'aux
échecs aux échecs à un moment donné de
la partie il ya en gros une vingtaine ou
une trentaine de coups différents
possibles
je crois que
au tout début de la partie 1 pour pour
l'ouverture le premier coup y'a 20 20
coups possibles et puis après ça
augmente un petit peu généralement mais
enfin ça tourne autour d'une trentaine
de coups possibles au go quand vous
commencez la partie donc on à dire la
partie débute la partie la grille
évident et c'est une grille de 19 par 19
donc il ya 360 et une position quand
vous allez poser votre première pierre
vous avez 360 et une position possible
quand l'adversaire va répliquer il à 360
position possible et ainsi de suite
vous voyez que le nombre de coups
possibles 1 en donnée de la partie il
est beaucoup plus important au go qu'aux
échecs et ça ça augmente beaucoup la
complexité d'une recherche en arbres
parce qu'on peut anticiper maximum
quelques coups mais ça devient très
difficile ensuite d'anticiper au delà
parce qu'il faudrait une puissance de
calcul vraiment vraiment démentiel donc
ça c'est vraiment une première
différence essentielle entre entre le
jeu de go et le jeu d'échecs qui fait
qu'une recherche en art brutale marche
pas très bien il ya une deuxième
différence essentielle c'est que quand
vous faites une recherche en arbre je
vous ai dis donc vous anticipez sur
plusieurs coups à l'avance et puis vous
regardez une fois joué plusieurs coups
enfin le foie simuler plusieurs coups
quelle est la situation la plus
avantageuse pour faire ça vous avez
besoin d'un critère pour décider qu'est
ce que ça veut dire que la situation est
plus avantageuse une situation est plus
avantageuse qu'une autre et hamza besoin
d'un critère de décision pour comparer
des issues possibles et décider laquelle
est la plus favorable pour vous faire ça
aux échecs c'est pas extrêmement
compliqué si vous savez un peu jouer aux
échecs et que vous regardez un plateau
avec une partie en cours de route vous
êtes capable de juger à peu près lequel
des deux joueurs est le mieux bar et ce
genre de choses donc on peut assez
facilement évaluer la force d'une
position aux échecs ne serait-ce que
déjà compté le nombre de pièces qui sont
toujours en jeu le nombre de pièces
qu'on s'est fait manger etc ça aux
gosses est beaucoup plus difficile
certes ya pas de critères un peu
objectif mathématiques pour comparer
plusieurs positions et dire finalement
laquelle de ses positions et la plus
intéressante
c'est quelque chose au jeu de go qui
fait beaucoup appel à l'intuition
feeling alors moi c'est encore une fois
je suis pas joueur de gommer de ce que
je comprends de ce que nous disent les
joueurs de go il ya vraiment une part
vraiment de
feeling d'évaluation un peu globale des
forces sur le sur le plateau pour
décider si une position est plus
avantageuse qu'une autre et ça c'est
extrêmement difficile à formaliser et
donc ça rend difficile l'utilisation de
recherche en arbres parce qu'on l'a dit
pour faire une recherche en arbre il
faut que vous ayez un critère objectif
numérique pour comparer un certain
nombre d'issues possible et décider de
quelle est la meilleure
ce genre de critères on appelle ça une
fonction d'évaluations donc voilà le
faire une fonction d'évaluation aux
échecs c'est faisable au go c'est
extrêmement difficile étant donné la
nature du jeu
alors ces raisons là elles font que ça a
été pendant longtemps très difficile de
faire un algorithme qui savent jouer
correctement au go dans les années 90
donc à l'époque où ou deep blue a battu
kasparov aux échecs
à cette époque là les meilleurs
programmes de go informatique
il perdait contre un enfant sachant à
peu près bien joué donc voilà on est
très très loin de ce qui se passait aux
échecs et le seul le seul type de
situation où on arrivait à avoir des
programmes qui arrivé à rivaliser avec
des joueurs humains
c'était c'était en jouant sur des
grilles plus petit donc par exemple des
grilles de neuf par neuf donc mais que
en termes de complexité on est très loin
de la grille 19 par 19 du vrai goût ont
joué sur des grilles plus petit ou alors
en donnant un handicap aux joueurs
humains donc ça en fait ça se passe en
donnant des pierres davance des coudes
avance au programme et donc fallait
donner plusieurs couloirs parfois une
dizaine ou une quinzaine de coups d'
avance au programme pour qu'il puisse
rivaliser avec un joueur humain voilà
donc dans les années 90 on est et on
était vraiment très très loin d'avoir
des programmes qui sont capables de
rivaliser avec des joueurs la situation
s'est un peu améliorée améliorée dans
les années 2000 notamment avec de
nouveaux types d'algorithmes qu'on
appelle mcts à l'om c'était servir
monte-carlo tri search donc tri search
ça veut dire recherche en arbre c'est
vraiment le principe que je vous ai
décrit tout à l'heure donc l'eau si tu
as construit à l'arbre des possibilités
et à choisir la situation la plus
favorable et monte carlo en fait c'est
une variante de ce principe de recherche
en arbre dans lequel on va utiliser le
principe de choisir des coûts au hasard
alors pourquoi on fait ça en fait quand
dans le cas du jeu de go on a un arbre
qui est vraiment énorme
laure et du fait qu'il ya énormément de
possibilités au lieu d'explorer tous et
ben on va tirer au hasard un certain
nombre de coups qu'on va faire et qu'on
va explorer on va explorer seulement
certaines parties de l'arbre et on va
choisir au hasard les parties de l'arbre
qu'on va explorer ce qui permet de
gagner du temps l'autre astuce c'est que
plutôt que d'essayer de s'arrêter après
un certain nombre de coûts et du coup
d'être d'avoir ce problème de dévaluer
la force d'une position
une technique quand on fait la technique
monte carlo c'est de tirer au hasard
plein de coups et de jouer la partie
afin de simuler la partie jusqu'au bout
au hasard et quand on fait ça en fait ça
résout un peu le problème de
l'évaluation de la position parce que du
coup on n'a plus besoin d'un critère
pour décider si une position est bonne
ou pas de toute façon on va simuler la
partie jusqu'au bout et puis le critère
c'est très simple c'est est ce qu'on
gagne la partie où est ce qu'on la gagne
pas donc on explore voilà des parties de
l'arbre comme ça tirait au hasard mais
en jouant la partie jusqu'au bout et
donc ça permet de pallier un peu au
problème de la recherche en arbre
classique
appliqué au jeu de go et ça a permis que
dans les années 2000 on commence à avoir
des programmes qui qui commençait à
jouer correctement alors jouer
correctement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que quand on les faisait jouer
contre des joueurs humains de bon très
bon niveau
il fallait quand même soit jouée sur des
grilles réduite soit donnée quand même
un certain nombre de pierre davant sont
au programme qu'on n'était pas du tout
encore à jeu égal mais enfin il ya
certain nombre de progrès qui ont été
faits et un moment donné même il y avait
un programme français je crois que ça
plaît mogo qui était le champion du
monde des programmes informatiques de 2e
tour donc voilà donc ça c'était grâce à
la technique monte-carlo tsui search
alors maintenant le programme dont on
parle aujourd'hui qui s'appelle alpha go
donc a été développé par par une filiale
de google
qu'est ce qu'il a de nouveau par rapport
à ça en fait il reprend le principe de
la recherche en arbre en tirant au
hasard mais avec en ajoutant quelque
chose qui vient de certains algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle qu'on
appelle les algorithmes d'apprentissage
le principe des algorithmes
d'apprentissage en gros c'est que ce
sont des algorithmes qui sont capables
d'apprendre à faire quelque chose en
regardant une base de données
l'exemple est donc là en fait la base de
données d'exemple ce sont des partis de
gauche ont été joués par des joueurs
professionnels ou une base de données de
partie qui contient tous les coups joués
les uns après les autres par les joueurs
et on fait des algorithmes qui vont
aller examiner et analyser ces bases de
données et qui vont essayer de
d'apprendre à jouer comme comme les
joueurs professionnels voilà donc c'est
tout ce domaine qu'on appelle
l'apprentissage et plus précisément
alors je vais pas rentrer dans les
détails là dessus mais le type
d'apprentissage qui a été utilisé c'est
ce qu'on appelle le dip learning donc
c'est quelque chose qui est très à la
mode je referai une vidéo spécifique sur
le sur le dip learning je vais pas
rentrer dans les détails là dessus ce
qui est assez intéressant c'est de voir
comment vraiment ils ont utilisé ces
algorithmes de deep learning pour pour
enrichir la méthode de recherche en
arbre et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'en fait ils ont fabriqué deux deux
formes si vous voulez d'algorithmes
d'apprentissage
ils ont fabriqué un premier algorithmes
dont le but est d'apprendre à explorer
seulement les parties les plus
intéressantes de l'arbre donc on a dit
le principe de la recherche en arbre
monte carlo c'est qu'on va tirer au
hasard des parties de l'arbre qu'on va
aller explorer et la lidc de pâtir et
complètement au hasard mais c'est
d'essayer d'explorer un peu
intelligemment les bonnes parties de
l'arbre celles qui ont des chances de
conduire à des positions intéressantes
et donc voilà donc ils ont ils ont créé
un premier algorithme qui est sous la
forme de ce qu'on appelle un réseau de
neurones ou un réseau de neurones
artificiels dont l'objectif est
d'apprendre à explorer les parties
intéressantes de l'arbre plutôt que
d'aller explorer les parties
inintéressante et puis ils ont créé un
deuxième réseau de neurones dont le
principe est d'apprendre à ajustement
évaluer la force d'une position
c'est-à-dire pas jouer la partie enfin
si mais la partie jusqu'au bout pour
décider de la force d'une position mais
d'essayer d'avoir un réseau de neurones
qui soit capable de mettre un chiffre
là-dessus terre de de prédire la force
d'une position donnée sur le plateau et
donc voilà donc en combinant ces deux
réseaux de neurones avec une méthode de
recherche en arbre ils ont créé un
algorithme qui donc examine seulement
les bonnes parties de l'arbre
et puis s'arrête suffisamment tôt dans
l'examen de l'arbre et utilise son
deuxième réseau de neurones pour évaluer
la force d'une position et donc voilà
c'est comme ça que que cet algorithme
nom qui s'appelle alpha go a réussi
abattre lycée dole donc d un des
meilleurs du joueur de go du monde ce
que je trouve assez intéressant en fait
avec
avec cet algorithme c'est que finalement
ils jouent un peu de la manière dont on
joue nous les humains c'est à dire que
moi par exemple quand je quand je joue
aux échecs mais en fait je crois que je
joue un peu comme ça c'est à dire
j'essaye dans une situation donnée
d'évaluer un peu les options possibles
donc j'essaye d'évaluer l'arbre mais en
même temps je ne regarde pas toutes les
options possibles vous allez on a une
espèce d'intuition de savoir quels sont
les coûts intéressants à aller examiner
donc en fait on fait exactement ça à
dire qu'on a une une forme de de manière
d'explorer l'arbre des possibilités qui
nous fait ne pas trop regarder les
possibilités qu'ont pas l'air
intéressante et plutôt se focaliser sur
les possibilités intéressantes
et puis c'est pareil en fait pour la
partie évaluation c'est à dire que quand
on évalue plusieurs positions
différentes
en fait on ne fait pas forcément un
conte objectif mathématiques de bachar
en fait on a une espèce d'intuition de
savoir comment est ce qu'une position
est meilleure qu'une autre et c est donc
se trouve ça assez intéressant que
finalement l'algorithme alpha go il
reproduit exactement ce processus à une
recherche en arbre où on a une intuition
de quelles sont les parties de l'arbre
les plus intéressantes et on essaie
d'avoir une intuition de comment on
compare les forces de positions
différentes
voilà alors on va tout de suite coupé
court à tous à tous les commentaires un
peu défaitiste du genre oui
l'intelligence artificielle va bientôt
bouffe etc
je vous le dis en fait selon jia s'était
complètement attendu qu'un jour le
on aurait un algorithme qui soit capable
de jouer au goût au niveau des meilleurs
joueurs du monde
même si un certain nombre de
spécialistes pensaient que quand même
quand même ça prendra plus de temps
mais voilà bon ok le gobal à la machine
est meilleur que l'homme c'est vrai que
c'est un peu symbolique parce que le go
donc en tout cas parmi les jeux
abstraits était quand même probablement
celui donc qu'on imaginait le plus
difficile pour une machine
enfin voila je pas parce qu'un
ordinateur c'est jouer au gault au
niveau mondial que l'intelligence
artificielle va nous bouffer il reste
plein de choses que que les algorithmes
ne savent pas ne savent pas encore faire
voilà et puis et puis en guise de
conclusion donc je vous ai dit je ferai
aussi prochainement une vidéo plus
spécifique sur sur le dip learning pour
expliquer qu est-ce que c'est ce titre
d'algorithmes pourquoi ça a été une
petite révolution dans l'est dans les
quelques dernières années est en fait
notamment le fait que alpha go qui
utilise des algorithmes de diplômes ning
et atteint ce niveau de performance et
fait aussi partie de cette petite
révolution
donc voilà donc je vous ferai très
prochainement une vidéo sur le diplôme
voilà j'espère que ça vous aura un peu
éclairé sur cette cette grande nouvelle
concernant l'intelligence artificielle
et legault et puis on se retrouve
bientôt pour de nouvelles vidéos
à bientôt